i'm here at comic-con where there's been
a lot of buzz around the upcoming reboot
of the Godzilla franchise from an
American production company now people
are excited because it promises to be
the opposite of the 1998 America
Godzilla film which took the idea of the
giant lizard but jettisoned everything
else that made the franchise such a
touchstone just look at this get some
candy don't want anything to be home Oh
horrible this new film is directed by
Gareth Edwards whose low-budget
science-fiction flick monsters had the
sort of embedded social commentary we
associate with Godzilla but cast
includes people who appeared in the
original 1954 classic and the Godzilla
encounter installation here at comic-con
features props from the original films
and audio evidence that the creature
will emit the same terrifying roar as
the original Godzilla did nevertheless I
am extremely skeptical about this new
film because Godzilla will be entirely
computer-generated now people laugh at
the stiff awkward movement of the suit
actor in the original Godzilla or the
unconvincing miniature cities he
destroys but the main reason we still
care about Godzilla is that we sensed
that there was a flesh-and-blood
creature inside of that suit the only
way a computer-generated version will
work is if they dress up an actor in the
old bulky Godzilla suit record his
performance on a motion-capture stage
then they can map his movements on to
their hundred-million-dollar CG anything
else would be a sacrilege
you